all right so I I know that on my
community tab I said I wasn't going to
talk about the ukulele apology and I'm
not I've got other stuff to deal with
[Music]
that was that was a stupid throwaway
joke
whatever we're moving on
Jonathan Majors the actor who has been
playing Kang in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe there have been enough new
developments on the situation that has
been going on with him that I felt it
was time for me to do an update uh since
I know I've gotten a fair few more
people on since the Illuminati video a
quick overview in general as I mentioned
there I don't really like to talk about
these things too much but when I do I
tend to frame them through the lens of
the potential Fallout impact and the
career perspectives what I don't do is I
don't spend my time focusing on parsing
who's right who's wrong uh who's lying
who did what who's most at fault I have
no interest in that especially with
something that is ongoing like this
where I don't know what's going on that
having been said I'm not saying I don't
have opinions there is often a direction
that evidence will lean but whatever my
opinion on who did or didn't do
something is not the focus of these
videos nor the point is bring you up to
speed feed and helping to put into
context where things currently stand
with people often connected to stuff
that I otherwise talk of talk about like
the MCU like DC adaptations like Jaw
Sweden unfortunately back when I had to
talk about that
Etc et cetera Etc
so
Jonathan majors
three months ago he was arrested in
regards to assault
um allegations and there is a trial date
uh at least one co-star has spoken up
somewhat in his defense and there has
been a new Wrinkle in regards to the
person who accused him and there's also
been a very in-depth piece put out by
the Rolling Stone that happened at time
of recording I think just yesterday so
I've got a bit to catch up on now first
thing that I feel like I'm just gonna
touch on and get out of the way because
it's kind of the elephant in the room a
lot of people since the beginning of
this have been comparing Jonathan Majors
situation to Ezra Miller
uh over at DC Ezra Miller played The
Flash and I did more than my fair share
of videos on them uh dealing with
everything that they had gotten up to
but in terms of the comparison it's a
natural one for folks to make in that
while the time period over which Ezra
Miller was pulling a lot of nonsense
um the time period of that was a lot
longer that was ongoing and right now
what we have at least in terms of formal
charges is very limited to one incident
with Majors it was still a major fixture
of what was supposed to be someone who's
going to be a big part of the future of
a major franchise
and suddenly is it a good idea to keep
them on board
now funnily with Ezra Miller
um Warner Brothers might have lucked out
with the fact that the Flash movie
underperformed like I don't doubt they
would have liked it to have done well
just because of how long it was in
development and how expensive it was but
at the same time I have to imagine that
when it comes to Ezra Miller they're
breathing at least a little bit of
relief because they can choose to not
move forward with that version of The
Flash character and justify it strictly
on the fact that the box office
underperformed and not have to touch any
of the allegations anymore and so that
actually kind of gives Warner Brothers a
free pass
Disney it's worth noting Disney and
Marvel despite what some people seem to
think have not actually formally fired
or removed or announced the departure of
or replacement of Jonathan Majors we
already know that they were planning a
lot with him he is supposed to be the
major villain we already know he is in
low-key season two some other stuff may
have been shot uh plan for a future
Avengers movie is literally called Kang
Dynasty it's pretty big now I've talked
before about the logistics of replacing
him like feasibly they could but there's
still a lot of problems with the look of
it especially with this being an ongoing
story and I mentioned one of his
co-stars sort of coming out a little bit
in defense of him that was Anthony
Mackey and I think when Anthony Mackey
sends kind of speaks to why this is a
bit of a dicey situation for
um for Disney and for Marvel Anthony
Mackey despite what some headlines said
which made it sound a lot more like he
was giving a full throw to defense he
wasn't what Anthony Mackey said was the
man is supposed to be innocent until
proven guilty now given the fact that
Jonathan Majors is black as is Anthony
Mackey so he would come to it with that
perspective I don't think it's unfair
for him to highlight the fact that
Jonathan majors has gotten massively
condemned and though while not fired
from Marvel as yet he was dropped by his
talent agency something that never
happened to Ezra Miller and there were
all these calls and these pushes over
one thing versus Miller where yes there
were certainly calls to get rid of them
but you know they held on and have
really for all intentimes and purposes
not faced a heck of a lot of
consequences
so it makes a lot of sense to me that
Maggie would basically go look the man
is innocent until proven guilty and
nothing is proven because
it's hard to claim that race is no
factor in this which is probably part of
why Marvel and Disney have been really
cautious about saying much of anything
other than you know things are ongoing
because
um to even though like Miller is over at
Warner Brothers different company
there's still an inherent comparison
that just gets made in people's minds
and it looks like you are far more
willing to drop the black man at the
first uh sign of trouble versus the
white person over another Studio who was
kept on through a lot of nonsense now
again is that a fair comparison to make
given that there are different companies
I honestly don't know the nature of
exactly how much race plays into this
and the coverage of how other outlets or
other people on YouTube even have talked
about Jonathan Majors is not really
something that I am properly equipped to
deal with uh however it's definitely
there and it's in play and at least the
impression that I got was probably a at
least a notable part of why Anthony
Mackey said what he said and I think
what he said under the circumstances
makes sense again it's weird to me that
some Outlets put out headlines that made
it seem much more like he was saying no
he definitely didn't do it which he
wasn't all he really did was say can we
wait until this thing hits its end
before everybody judges him which
you know in theory is how it's supposed
to work although the reality is very
messy I've noted before that
um innocent until proven guilty is the
duty of the legal system the court the
court of public opinion is not beholden
to it and never has been and never will
be but that's a whole other thing so
that's sort of the background that we're
dealing
what's new
well uh a couple of things as I said we
have a trial date August 3rd which is
coming up not too long in the future and
is actually a little bit odd because at
this point the charges that Majors is
facing aren't felony charges they're
misdemeanor charges
and it it's very uncommon for
misdemeanor charges to see trial
generally they get pled down to a lower
count people plead guilty they pay a
fine or do community service and then
they move on that's the normal way that
things move forward but this really does
look like it's going to go to trial hold
on to that I am going to come back to it
because I think there is a reason for
that
um but for right now just be aware trial
date is set now
majors and his legal team have uh issued
their own complaint of assault and abuse
against the person who originally
accused him basically the
um New accusations that he is laying and
like have actually been made formally
legally because since the beginning his
legal team has kind of been like oh
actually she was the abusive one but now
they're kind of putting their money
where their mouth is and actually
pushing forward on the legal end of that
claiming that um she assaulted him that
on the night of the incident she was
drunk and he was trying to either assist
and or restrain her
um now it's worth noting that in general
this kind of Na you tactic to an
accusation especially when it comes to
somebody with means and notoriety is
very common and while it is certainly by
no means impossible for that account for
majors in his lawyers accounts to be the
the accurate one or at least the more
accurate one it is still a fairly common
tactic to basically flip it around and
try to discourage the other party from
moving forward with any accusations
because you're like hey I'm gonna drag
you down with my own accusations against
you now in New York where all this is
taking place the authorities are
actually obligated to determine a
primary aggressor in a case of you know
Mutual accusations each one accusing the
other but even with that in place it is
not impossible for charges to actually
be levied against both parties even the
one who's determined to not be the
primary aggressor and that is like
whether it's meant to be or not that is
realistically one of the reasons why
some people are hesitant to come forth
and bring charges because this kind of
thing happens again that in and of
itself does not mean that the
accusations that majors and his legal
team are putting against his own initial
accuser are wrong I'm just trying to
give you the context of how these things
tend to happen now what's interesting
and what's worth giving this a little
more weight than I might have otherwise
because like one legal side who has a
client who's been accused of someone
going nah you that's basically like
that's very typical it's a very typical
tactic to the point that it's like it's
not worth noting anything what is worth
noting though is uh there is word and
it's been not officially confirmed by
the NYPD but sourced reliably that they
have what's called an i card
um on the accuser now an icard is not
the same as an arrest warrant that's
worth stressing but what it is is it's
basically a confirmation of probable
cause for an arrest so again it's not an
arrest warrant she does not have an
arrest warrant against her but what she
does have is a notice from the police
that basically says if we wanted to move
forward with this we have problem cause
to do so so it's kind of a step one that
does not always lead to later steps it
does not always result in a warrant and
an arrest and charges but when charges
arrest warrant you know you track that
back
it often starts with not always but it
often starts with an i card so there's
the potential that she will be facing
her own charges and if so the first step
has occurred
now obviously from the perspective of
majors and uh his legal team this is
great because it seems to validate their
angle that they are taking uh on all
this and I suppose the other thing that
I don't want to get too bogged down into
the specifics of exactly what he was
accused of partly because I don't really
want to get into that kind of details
which I know can be unsettling for
people to hear but she did revise her
initial accusation slightly initially
she made a claim that he put a hand on
her neck she has removed that but has
held on to pretty much all of her other
accusations
um in some form if not exactly as she
laid them out initially which is of
course another thing that legal teams
tend to jump on this idea that she's
changing her story all this might not
have been enough to have it be worth a
new video
if it were not for the article that
Rolling Stone put out which I mentioned
earlier now in this article
for which they interviewed over 40
people over the course of three months
so basically after the initial arrest of
Jonathan Majors happened they dove into
interviewing people who knew him from
various points in his history and
it's not great so if you didn't watch my
initial video on majors's arrest which
you can see there I went into this in
more detail there but at the time there
were at least two people who had known
him for some time
um mainly going back to a time at the
David Geffen uh drama school at Yale and
they basically said yeah this behavior
from him is kind of what we've always
known about him those people being Tim
Nikolai and a B Allen well the over 40
people that Rolling Stone has since
interviewed uh most of whom didn't give
their name and some of whom only made a
statement of I can't talk to you because
I signed an NDA
um they pretty much the ones who were
able to go into any more detail
corroborated the picture that those two
people initially painted now as part of
that article Rolling Stone did say that
they ran the initial version of the
article by
um majors's legal team to see if they
had any comment they wanted to issue and
there was a statement given to
um Rolling Stone by the legal team in uh
in response to what was in the article
and ultimately that response probably
did more damage so the response in and
of itself is kinda boilerplate you know
it's you know we disagree with this
assessment these are Anonymous people
noting that even though um a fair amount
of the people who were interviewed noted
that while not all of his abusive
behavior that they recall having seen
was always towards romantic Partners
sometimes it was uh co-stars crew Etc
um you know Backstage on set sort of
things but most of the more egregious
stuff was noted as being towards
romantic Partners however none of the
interviewed people were in fact any of
those romantic partners that was
something that Majors his legal team
pointed out which you'd expect them to
under the circumstances now people can
have their own assumptions that they
will make about why or why not the
actual romantic partners that according
to the Rolling Stone uh article over a
dozen people noted uh on the that these
women underwent some kind of a mental
physical or emotional abuse at the hand
of Majors it's not nothing to point out
that well they didn't say anything there
are of course many reasons why they
might not they might not want the
attention even some of the people who
did speak out apparently said that they
were nervous to do so because they
didn't want these people to be targeted
even though they aren't named but I
think it would have been very difficult
for any of these women to come forward
and talk about their specific
experiences without having whatever
specific thing they cite make it very
clear at least to majors and his legal
team who they are and therefore make
them vulnerable so it's not super
surprising to me that they didn't speak
but it's also not surprising that Majors
as lawyers would go see they didn't say
anything against him and use that or at
least try to use that to their advantage
as I said the response from his legal
team pretty boilerplate but then then
they did something that I think I think
they're probably really regretting right
now they sent over six bits of testimony
from character witnesses that they claim
were people who had actually dated
Jonathan majors at some point basically
the um approach they appear to be taking
was that okay you're putting all this
stuff out in your article well you
didn't interview anyone who actually
dated him and we have six testimonies
from people who did or were incredibly
close to him about as close as someone
who was dating him would have been and
they have all these glowing things to
say
which might have been okay
except that Rolling Stone then got in
contact with those six people
that Majors as lawyers
um uh gave these character statements
from
and that's where things get really
really bad not necessarily for Majors
himself but at least in terms of like
whose fault this is this is his lawyer's
fault this is not his fault what I'm
about to talk about this is his lawyers
they did something really dumb
because when Rolling Stone reached out
to these Six Women
three of them
said that they did not give clearance
for those statements to be shared or
issued or made public one of them said
that the statement was not truly written
by her it was pre-written for her that
it was not truthful and she did not okay
the release of it one didn't uh respond
to request and then of the six one did
respond basically saying I have only
glowing things to say about him I know
him to be a wonderful person and that
was someone who he did date
from the ages of 13 to 18.
now I'm not going to say that how
somebody behaved in their youth is like
completely irrelevant but like
we're talking 15 to 20 years ago was the
period in which she dated him and that
was the only one of the six character
witness testimonials that stood by what
was provided to Rolling Stone when this
hits trial
I really really hope that for Jonathan
Majors to say because like regardless of
whether you think he did it or not
this is incompetence in terms of
representation
and like nobody should have a lawyer
that pulls skeevy nonsense but you
should have a competent lawyer
like you just should
so honestly while I'm still not gonna
like make any different claims of he
definitely did or definitely didn't do
this but like for anyone I would hope
that their that their legal team
is better than this reflects or implies
them to be
because
oh geez
that said uh that comes back to the
trial date now as I mentioned uh these
kinds of misdemeanor charges almost
never see the inside of a courtroom they
don't see trial and it is kind of
surprising that this hasn't actually
gotten pleaded down and gone away
I suspect I know why though
I think that Jonathan Majors probably
especially considering how quickly his
agency dropped him his representation
dropped him he probably has a sense of
his position of his notoriety of his
career
being incredibly tenuous
and
if he were to plead guilty
even though it would be to a smaller
charge even though it would be a
misdemeanor
that it would probably be the end of his
career certainly at the level that he
has it at
and again I'll Circle back to what I
said when I brought up Anthony Mackey's
statement there's probably an issue of
race in there he probably has a sense
that he can't have it on his record
because it will at the very least kill
all of his current career momentum
and in an effort to in to prevent that
he it looks like he's going to try and
go to trial or at least keep pushing
towards trial maybe hoping that the
whole thing gets dropped but if it
doesn't roll the dice on getting a full
acquittal of getting to a point to a not
guilty verdict and say C I had a fair
trial they said no because while as I
said the court of public opinion moves
forward regardless
he's going to be on a much better
standing to try and recoup his career
if he can say I was acquitted then if he
says I pled guilty to a smaller charge
because as I've noted for years when it
comes to companies like Disney
ultimately when they fire people
for Stuff related to this they're not
actually making a judgment about the
morals of the person involved
they're not people will assume they are
they're not they're making a judgment
based on the public response and
reception of keeping them on versus
getting rid of them uh the instance that
I've talked about in the past that I
think illustrates this the best is what
happened with Gina Carano when she was
fired off the Mandalorian and any other
subsequent Star Wars related material
for her continually uh right-wing
anti-vaxx and uh eventually anti-semitic
postings on social media she had it
brought to her attention that she needed
to stop because she kept making
headlines for bad reasons and every time
she was in a headline it was Star Wars
star causes controversy she was damaging
the brand she was warned she kept doing
it she wasn't gone because she crossed
the moral boundary she was gone because
she was generating too much bad press
and when it comes to Jonathan majors
if Disney or Marvel ever get rid of him
it's not going to be because they do or
don't think he did what he's accused of
it's going to be because they need to
weigh does it look worse if we get rid
of him or does it look worse if we keep
him around
and
I think the answer to that is going to
be heavily influenced by whether or not
he has a guilty plea even on a
misdemeanor versus he has an acquittal
because an acquittal is probably going
to tip the balance in favor of it's
better for us to keep him on
whereas a guilty plea even on a lesser
charge is probably going to tip it in on
the side of we should get rid of him now
it's not consequence free either way
Disney and Marvel are going to get
called out and accused of one thing or
another you know protecting a a powerful
man or or
um going after and rejecting someone
who's uh in their stable of actors who
is black or you know no matter what they
do they're gonna face some degree of
backlash the calculus is going to be
what is the worst one and then you avoid
that and as I said I think it's going to
be heavily influenced by the results of
this trial if it does actually go
forward
now there's another factor in this
because one of the reasons
um especially with someone as notable as
Majors that these things get
um pleated down not only to avoid the
inside of a courtroom but like Trials
take time
and
people lose work
because of I mean officially scheduling
conflicts but like if you're busy going
to court can you shoot another movie
this is actually kind of where other
stuff completely unrelated might be both
to
um Jonathan majors and Disney's benefit
and that's the strikes currently we're
in what month two of the writers strike
there is a potential imminent actor
strike as well and these like the writer
strike
some things did are still moving forward
and getting shot but it's preventing new
stuff from getting written so at a
certain point stuff that already got
written is gonna be used up and so
production is going to hold on that it
might halt even sooner if the actors go
on strike
but that means that
both Jonathan majors and Disney have
more time to wait and see how this plays
out as opposed to making a decision
early on
and risking being wrong
because another thing that I mentioned
when I brought up
um Jonathan majors in my initial video
on all this I'm not surprised that
Disney is being really cautious about
how quickly they let people go even Gina
Carano she had to keep causing problems
repeatedly I think Disney is still
remembering the pain
of what happened with James Gunn quick
overview of that uh he had some very old
tweets with some very off-color not good
and unpleasant humor very edge Lord
humor in them brought up and he was
fired by Disney because it's not
consistent with their brand and their
family image
um of course it turned out later that
the outrage about this was completely
manufactured and was started by people
who dug this stuff up specifically with
the intent of trying to get him fired
because they didn't like his opinions
about Donald Trump so Disney really had
egg on their face after this which is
evident by the fact that Gunn
immediately went over to DC made The
Suicide Squad movie they had to beg him
to come back to make Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 and now he's back over at DC
again managing their whole thing Disney
acted really quick in response to a
controversy with James Gunn instead of
waiting to really see the true nature of
what was going on or the true nature of
what people were gonna think about it
because yeah some people did see that
and get outraged but as it played out
most people went
dude you just gave in to a to a
completely contrived hate mob what's
wrong with you
so I think Disney right now is way more
cautious about acting too fast and I
think they're probably more than happy
uh the opportunity to have more time to
let it play out and not have looming
starts of filmings of various things
force them to make a decision before
they know the outcome
because Disney's in a position where
there's two things conflicting with this
kind of situation on the one hand in
terms of the pr and like knowing that
they've made the right call the best
thing to do is wait and see what happens
and so to know that there is an outcome
you know either that he pled guilty or
there's an outcome at trial and then you
make a decision based off that because
if you make a decision sooner than that
basically it looks like you have judged
him before the courts have
and right now that's not necessarily
good looking that's bitten them in the
ass already
but on the other hand there's only so
long you can wait when you've got
schedules announced when you have
shareholders who are going to go hey why
isn't more stuff coming out you said you
were going to have this movie or this
series out by X date where the hell is
it you can only delay for so long but
now they have an artificial thing
delaying everything further and that's
the strikes
so without the strikes I think there's a
chance that Disney might have had to
make a call if only because they were
going to start butting up against
shooting start times for some of the
things that Majors was going to be in if
I can get speculated for a minute if I
were to guess they probably would have
removed him from smaller Cameo
appearances like in build up stuff
um or replace them with another villain
but probably would not have formally
fired him but held on that call until
after the outcome of trial but they're
not even in that situation right now
because with the strikes going on until
everything gets resolved nothing can
move forward so they don't even have to
make that much of a call yet
and in a way as I said Jonathan Majors
kind of benefits from this too because
it means that the big uh the biggest
company that employs and you know the
biggest uh aspect of his career right
now
doesn't have a reason to rush their call
and whether or not that's good for him
in the long run again will ultimately
depend on the outcome of if this sees
trial and how that goes and
we'll see I suppose it's just been
really interesting to see this play out
because
and this is why I do tend to talk about
these things when they come up there's
little tiny differences or little weird
sort of
um monkey wrenches in the gears that
just make it different from the other
times because people like to be really
reductive uh and be like oh well like
this person was fired for this thing but
this person wasn't like there's a lot of
tiny differences that can result in a
vastly different outcome
and that's why I find it interesting to
talk about
again we're not at the end so I I'll
probably have at least
one more video on this uh depending on
the outcome at trial if it goes to trial
um but we'll see for right now that's
the current standing on the situation
with Jonathan Majors as I uh understand
it and realizing that while I do my best
to do research
uh I am one person I am fallible but I
do my best
what did you think about all this
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can't help me out that way like
share subscribe our big help
but uh don't worry too much about it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you're valid
and you are loved
you are the council and I'm just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen Leota
Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks for
Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell Tracy
scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL Taylor
David Hall Shayla Gourley and Rosalind
Bennett thanks for your support you can
get your name and the credits too if you
feel like hearing me possibly struggle
with it for several times before getting
it right
foreign
[Music]